all right just when we're ready to take
the masks off a new variant is taking
off we don't know how dangerous it is we
do know it's led to a dramatic spike in
cases in china in europe particularly
italy and now here even in the big apple
in new york city it's called ba2 dr
anthony fauci the white house chief
medical advisor here now to explain if
this is a big deal we have to worry
doctor good to see you again
thank you neil good to see you glad to
see you back in full action again
no thank you for that um let me ask you
doctor about this ba2 should we worry
about it
well
we'll look at its characteristics and
and and we could make that determination
it's got a transmission advantage over
ba1 which is the classic original
omicron
not a multi-fold advantage but a
percentage advantage which means that
over time
it likely will be the dominant variant
worldwide
neil it's already about 91
of all
the recognizable isolates and in the
united states
it's creeping up 30 40 in some parts of
the country 50 percent
or more
it does not appear to be any more
serious when it comes to
complications like the need for
hospitalization and advanced disease and
it doesn't appear
that it escapes immune protection any
more or less than the original omicron
so the only distinguishing
feature
is that it's more transmissible which is
accounting
for the spikes that we're seeing
throughout the world including in the
european union in the uk
so now we've been in the process of
de-masking everywhere there's a push
even on the part of airline executives
to ask the government to end this
requirement that you have to wear mass
on planes or in airports what do you
think of all that are we doing it too
soon about right no need for panic how
would you describe it
well certainly i don't think there's a
need to panic neil the idea about too
soon or not is really
a judgment call we know that when you
pull back the three factors that causing
the spikes that we're seeing in the
european union and worldwide are as i
mentioned a moment ago the increased
transmissibility advantage of this
isolate the ba2
the pulling back on
some of the restrictions particularly
masking and indoor settings
and a general
waning of immunity from people who've
been vaccinated as well as people who've
gotten infected you've got to have a
balance we all want to return to agree
of normality one of the things that's
encouraging
certainly in the uk
and if we do get an increase here it
likely will mimic what we see in the uk
is that although the infections are
going up
it doesn't appear at least in the uk
data to be an increase
in hospitalizations with severe disease
certainly not an increased
requirement or usage
of intensive care beds
and the all-cause mortality
has not increased so
it may be that an expected increase in
cases
when you pull back
on some of the restrictions particularly
masking in an indoor setting so that's
really not surprising neil the question
is
will it have a major impact
on severity of disease which would be a
problem and then we'd have to reconsider
what we want to do in response to that
um as a new yorker yourself doctor um as
you're aware of mayor eric adams in new
york city has been getting a collective
bronx cheer for what some people
say is a double standard on vaccinations
uh lifting them for uh athletes and some
entertainers but not for everybody else
um how do you feel about that
well you know neil that that's obviously
a a delicate situation
in new york i'd really don't want to be
out there out guessing the mayor who i'm
sure is trying to do what's best
for the city but he made that decision
to pull back
on the requirement for vaccination for
certain entertainers and and sports
figures
in some of the athletic teams i mean as
you mentioned
there is a pushback on that that that
might be unfair to others but you know
i'm not there on the ground in new york
i don't have a good feel
for what the situation is so it really
is a tough problem so i'd rather not why
couldn't it be for everybody doctor i i
guess i'm saying if you're going to
not require vaccinations
for athletes and entertainers do the
same for everybody else or if you are
include the athletes and the
entertainers be consistent what do you
think
well again uh neil i i don't want to be
taking sides on that i think that the
mayor had a difficult decision to make
as you mentioned when you introduced the
topic
there's been a lot of pushback on that
because some are seeing it as unfair you
can understand that but you also have to
look at the mayor's side again it's a
tough call it's really a tough call
yeah i guess he wants those for home
games uh to to be able to play fair but
really if we're doing something that
helps the new york mets is that really a
good idea but leaving that aside doctor
leaving that aside um
when it comes to where we stand in this
battle last time we chatted you you know
you talked about the idea that um you
know we might be treating this like we
do the flu and a shot every year but now
you have companies like modern and
pfizer talking about up to
four shots if you include a couple of
booster shots i mean how far does this
go a lot of people are just confused
neil we don't know we do know that
the
protection of a vaccination and a boost
does wane
a study from the cdc in their vision
network cohort
showed that following a third dose when
you look at around four to five months
following the third dose the protection
against hospitalization
wanes from about 91 percent
down to 78
and the data from israel are even
more dramatic than that so the question
is a reasonable question
do you want to give a fourth dose at
least to some subset
of the population likely the elderly who
generally don't have as robust
and immune response as an otherwise
healthy
young person
the fda is looking at those data really
in real time right now there's also
going to be another aspect to it
it's the immediate question
of the waning that we're seeing now
should we or should we not
be making recommendations regarding a
fourth shot at least to some subgroup
but then probably the broader question
in the long run
is what about when we get to the late
summer and early fall
when there will be a considerable
duration of time
following the third boost in so many
people in the population
will the immunity wane enough
that you really would require for full
protection to get that fourth boost and
then
the subsequent question is the broader
one is how often
would we have to do this and to be quite
honest and candid neil we don't know
because this is just new territory for
us with this virus
and we don't know after you get for
example a fourth shot
will the durability be such that you
don't have to get a shot
like we do with the flu every year or
it might actually be required and i
think
it would really not be prudent for us to
guess because we don't know we just have
to take a look at the data
and follow the cohorts
and see if you have enough of a
diminution and protection
that you do get a serious spike in
hospitalizations again particularly
among people who are in the elderly
group we know for sure
that we absolutely need it for the
immune compromise there's no doubt about
that so that's already settled but for
the rest of the population it's a bit
unclear
yeah you know you talk about the the
have you compromised i'm in that uh
subset of the population i i i deal with
it but you know it's funny a doctor when
i returned after being out in the icu
dealing with a pretty serious bacterial
infection and you know something that i
certainly didn't expect after being
fully vaccinated uh to get coveted twice
and and the last time again quite severe
now i'm not saying that to talk about me
but to talk about others who then
questioned well if you've been
vaccinated kabuto would this happen to
you uh
who's to say that it wasn't the vaccine
that did it now of course i've talked to
a lot of doctors i got to talk to smart
people like you said that you know
because of that it could have been a lot
worse for me
but yeah but again it there's a there's
a sort of a
dark side coming out or a lot of people
saying the vaccine
wasn't and isn't worth it it's no good
it it it it almost kills people
and i
just curious to get your response to
that yeah well i think you know what my
response is going to be neil and i think
you yourself know we are sophisticated
enough that if you had not been
vaccinated neil you you and i may not be
having this conversation right now sadly
i'm so glad that you are here and we're
having this conversation but if you look
at the data the data really are crystal
clear
and speak for themselves if you look at
the general population and look at
hospitalizations and deaths
and compare the vaccinated with the
unvaccinated or even more importantly
the vaccinated plus boosted with the
unvaccinated
overwhelmingly
the hospitalization and deaths are among
the unvaccinated you and several others
in the population
are in a different category neil because
when you are immune compromised
you really don't have the kind of
natural response
to a vaccine or even to a prior
infection and that's the reason why
you're seeing us strongly recommend
the boosters for people who are immune
compromised but the idea
that the vaccine is causing harm here
the data overwhelmingly argue against
that
yeah i mean it's it's
indisputable but you know
i can bang my head against a brick wall
here there's no politics here in this
for me i just want people to be safe but
i'll leave that aside you recently had
said i believe in interview on abc with
george stephanopoulos about the issue of
retirement came up um you're 81 years
young
you weren't looking for that but i i
then started thinking about
what could happen uh in the next few
months or if republicans take control
of congress or the house and or senate
you would most likely
be a target of hearings and and them
going after you
are you ready for that do you fear that
do you think that you could handle that
where are you on this
well first of all i have absolutely
nothing to hide or nothing to be
concerned about of anything that i've
done so i
never have been am not now and will
never be afraid
of hearings done in good faith in
oversight i mean obviously if you looked
at some of the hearings
they started off out of nowhere to be ad
hominem attacks without even
asking a reasonable
question
uh and you've known that you've seen
that uh the clips of that neil that
that's not interesting
rand paul or senator rand paul who's
just said that you you were deemed the
dictator in chief on these members yeah
or starting off the conversation by
saying are you how do you feel about
being responsible for the death of five
million people which is absolutely
preposterous and slanderous so but
anyway your question is
my decision about
career and what i'm doing about what
what my role would be
is not at all influenced by any concern
about hearings or attacks
i get attacked now and i continue to do
my job
i have nothing to hide and certainly
nothing to fear
so if they were to subpoena you doctor
if they had control of said and one of
these i mean would you go
well i always uh
um abide by the natural lawful things i
mean if one gets subpoenaed one goes in
front of the congress
but you wouldn't avoid another if it
came to that
well i'm not sure what you're asking i
mean i i've never avoided anything that
had to do with congressional oversight
and i have no intention of avoiding it
okay but that's not doing it
and i don't i don't mean to belabor this
but i just want to be clear that if they
were to
look into the origins of this fire hold
special hearings on that and say dr
fauci we want you
down here to talk about this you would
say
i do it but neil i'm doing that already
so it isn't what i would do and i'm
doing that already i've testified before
multiple hearings and i will continue to
do that so this isn't anything new and
again that has nothing to do with how
long i stay in the government or not uh
it's completely unrelated
this whole shift when you first started
you were an international rock star
you know you were featured in
entertainment magazines you crossed
lines from far from just a top doctor to
to a cult uh following and and then the
pendulum shifted along with the increase
in cases and the second doubts and
questions about you
did you look at that and experience that
and say
this has not been worth it
no neil i i think you need to get a
perspective from how i look at it i'm a
physician
i'm a scientist i direct a very
important institute
one that has been responsible for the
most part for the development of the
vaccines that have saved millions of
lives already i don't think about it in
terms of
being a cult person and everybody
idolizing me and being a controversial
polarizing figure
where other people
you know do the kinds of things that
we've been talking about about attacking
me
either end of that spectrum
to me is irrelevant neil
my job is what's important and that is
which i've done
for now almost 40 years as director of
the institute making my goal the
preservation
and the protecting of the health
of the american people and indirectly
the health of the rest of the world
because the united states plays such an
important role
so the idea when you're idolized or
you're demonized i mean that's just a
reflection
of what's going on in society and really
has very little to do with what i am and
who i am and what i do
so you may not
believe it or appreciate it but all of
that other stuff is irrelevant it's my
job and what i do that's important
dr anthony falchief thank you very much
for joining us i appreciate it
thank you neil thank you for having me
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else